it's the beginning
of may 2021 so it's time for another
monthly update video i'm going to talk
about what we've got coming
up in the month of may and a bit about
april which was kind of a weird month
for reasons i'll tell you about in just
a minute i always like to begin by
highlighting three big things that i
want you to know about that are coming
up this month
so big thing number one is that i'm
going to be doing another
clubhouse event this time it's with my
wife
andy shaka and i'll tell you more about
that in the may section but it's called
greg and andy ramble on so if you're on
clubhouse you may want to check that out
big thing number two i
started doing a good bit of publication
in medium which
i you know i've had for a long time but
haven't really used that much and so
i wrote quite a few things in april and
i'm going to have a lot of things coming
out
in may so you may want to check that out
if you like my
longer form non-video non-podcast you
know written word
stuff and then finally big thing number
three
i'm going to be participating in the
stoicon x military conference i'll be
giving a
short talk on stoicism and what genuine
courage
as opposed to fake courage looks like
more about that in the may section
as a month april was kind of a bust
it started out pretty good but then i
got hit by
some serious bad news about midway
through the month that i think many of
you viewers or
listeners or subscribers already know
about and that is the death of my
my uncle amay you know my mother died
many years ago that's my mother's
brother
and there there were four of them my mom
two brothers aim and john and then my
aunt bibian who was a bit younger than
them
so now it's down to just two and they
are you know at the top of the food
chain in the family
at least our branch of the family you
might say so that was a real
um you know it wasn't totally out of the
blue
aim was 73 but you know anytime you have
a significant
death like that that tends to take the
wind out of your sails quite a bit
and um i ended up canceling some of my
events for the month we're also in the
process of wrapping up the semester
as we finish out april so there and this
time you know students are
really quite you know worn out uh after
two and a half semesters of covid times
i think that they've kind of reached the
end of their their tether
in many respects so i didn't get quite
as much done
for the month as i typically do i i did
hold my
public half hour hegel session and my
ama
and the worlds of speculative fiction
section
i also had my uh reach my celebration
for reaching 100 000 subscribers on
youtube
and then the news hit and then you know
things kind of
went downhill from there by the end of
the month i was ready to participate
in two conferences that i had either
um you know sent out a proposal to it it
was accepted
and then i'm on the hook for it like the
saint anselm conference
uh or i was asked to participate in it
and give a talk like the marcus aurelius
event with the
new acropolis
i also did some uh podcast interviews
and again earlier in the month
with the side view podcast and and the
stoic coach so i'll put links to those
down below and i did you know as i
pointed out quite a bit of
writing this this month on medium
including a piece about my uncle aim
which i'll link to here i also did a
video about him
as well and i finally bit the bullet and
created a publication in medium that i
can use to aggregate
my my stuff called practical rationality
i might be inviting some other
friends and colleagues to to join me
there
in writing pieces having to do with
practical philosophy
life you know ethics things things like
that
so i'll put a link to my medium
publication you might you might
find that interesting to read
videos i you know i didn't get as many
videos done
as i would have liked i had planned to
do four book reviews i got one book
review done
on kai whiting and
leonidas constitutacos's being better
about stoicism and i got two half hour
hegel
videos done which is a little you know
disappointing usually i like to get
six done a month but that doesn't happen
all the time
the event videos the ama the worlds of
speculative fiction the 1000
100 000 subscribers things those those
are all there for you to watch
as well and you can you know click the
see more
uh look at the video description you'll
see the links there
um i did a caption contest with ernie
and burt
and hegel and i also did a sadler
stories
um actually i did two saddler stories
one about my uncle aim and one about
something i remembered
spending some time with my dad i also
did another thing that's really taking
off
about 11 book volumes that i
that are my favorites and they're not my
favorite books necessarily but they are
about book volumes and a lot of people
are watching that and seemingly enjoying
it quite a bit
core concept videos i i wrapped up the
core concept videos on nietzsche's
genealogy of morals and then i jumped
into the
sigmund freud lecture 31
the dissection of the psychical
personality
i did six videos on that as well you
know about the super ego ego ed
kind of classic freud stuff and i did a
good bit of
podcast editing and releasing
finished up the stuff on thomas hobbs
released a sequence on
saint anselm's on freedom of choice
then uh six podcast episodes on franz
fanon's
black skin white masks and finally
finished up the month with a whole
sequence on lev chest offs
all things are possible and released one
video about play or not video podcast
episode
about plato's ion the very his shortest
work uh so there's not going to be an
awful lot of episodes
on that one so that that that's april
you know
not not the best month in in many
respects
but um you know there's quite a few
things that you might want to go back to
and check out
if you if you missed them and you're
interested in that sort of thing
so there's a lot going on in the month
of may we have a number of different
events
all of which are online still because
we're still in covid times that you
might want to
participate in or check out in one way
or another
we're starting the event a little bit
late on saturday the 8th
all times by the way central time so
make sure to check your time zones
so on saturday the 8th at 12 p.m i'll
have my monthly
ama that's ask me anything session
and you can pop in and it's sort of open
forum for about an hour and a half i try
to answer as many questions as i can
at 2 p.m then i'll also have my
philosophy
chat which is an exclusive session for
patreon supporters
at a certain level that's video
conferencing directly with me
rather than you know just watching a
streaming video and doing comments on on
the side
so it's a little bit more intimate if
that's something that you want to do
then
you might want to consider becoming a
patreon supporter
on the 12th at 5 p.m i'll have my public
hegel q a and discussion hour
anybody can come to that you don't have
to be a you know supporter of the half
hour hegel project
although most of the people who do tend
to be from that
and we're now you know deep in the
religion section
of hegel's phenomenology so that's
pretty cool
on the 13th i'm doing something quite
new i mentioned this
in the three big things so this is the
clubhouse event clubhouse is a platform
that
right now i think is only available to
ios that is apple you know iphone users
i don't think it's available on android
but they're working on it
be that as it may clubhouse is this
pretty cool
thing that allows you essentially to do
a party line and i've done one of them
before with massimo pigliucci
this time i'm doing it with my better
half andy shaka who
i think many of you already know and
it is going to be very open form it's
called greg and andy ramble on
and we're going to talk about whatever
we want to and you know
there's audience participation people
can ask questions make comments
um it's audio only so you know we'll
we'll see how many people
want to hear us doing our our shtick you
know we're both talkers
so you know there there will certainly
be a lot
that gets said during that um
on the 15th which is a saturday at 12
p.m
we'll have we'll resume our classic
medal class we didn't do it last month
uh in part because i was just too down
about my my uncle and didn't want to do
it
we will resume it this month and we're
talking about
um german bands german heavy metal from
you know the mid-1970s to the mid-1980s
before there's you know too many bands
to talk about
uh that should be a really interesting
session so
you can join me and my my friend scott
truly
for that that same day and i'm not sure
exactly what time because they haven't
put the schedule out but it'll be
later than two o'clock uh my time
i will be giving a talk in the stoicon x
military conference which you can sign
up for i
you know i believe it's it's uh actually
free
and i'll be talking about stoicism and
genuine courage
um i'll be recording it so if you miss
it you know you'll be able to watch it
later on
on the 16th the next day at 12 p.m
we will have another one of the events
that i didn't do in april
and got got pushed back to to may that's
the
political theory and practice discussion
and we'll be talking about
aristotle and his remarks about slavery
it turns out that aristotle's position
is a lot more
nuanced than a lot of people think you
know um
but we'll get into that during during
the session i'm sure it'll be quite
controversial
um but it should be a good session on
the
22nd uh at uh 12 p.m
we'll begin the worlds of speculative
fiction i think that's
uh session 52 which will be the third
session
on our scott backers prince of nothing
series we'll be looking at the
third book in the series the
thousand-fold thought
and it begins with a video premiere
where i'm presenting all sorts of cool
philosophical themes and developments
within the text and people can
do live chat on the side with me
for about an hour and a half and then
after that we switch to an interactive
zoom session where people can pop in and
we we talk
through the the works and we'll probably
be doing a lot of wrap up because
that'll be the last of
three sessions devoted to our scott
backer
on the 27th towards the end of the month
6 p.m
we have our mke that's milwaukee stoic
fellowship
and anybody can join from anywhere in
the world if they want to we
sometimes have people coming in from
brazil
you know people from other states in the
united states
and we're working on cicero's on duties
in that we're talking about the section
on temperance
and propriety and things like that the
other thing that i'll mention too
is that we have our wisdom for life show
that
airs every saturday at 4 pm on riverwest
radio
you can listen to it airing live
anywhere in the world just by going to
the
river west radio site and clicking on
listen
we also have the shows available later
on as podcast episodes
and as videos so you can you can check
those out
so that's a lot of stuff going on right
in addition to that
we're finishing up classes you know
carthage finished back in april
milwaukee institute of art and design
finished officially
um yesterday but i've got grading to do
so it's not finished for me yet right
and then milwaukee area technical
college classes don't end for a couple
weeks yet but i'm already getting ready
for my summer class
which is for milwaukee institute of art
and design i'm teaching a intro to
philosophy
class in six weeks and i'm really
rethinking and redesigning the class i
might do a video about this actually
because i am trying to instead of
teaching
sort of a traditional intro to
philosophy class i'm using the
opportunity of having this very
compressed time frame
and teaching students who are not going
to be philosophy majors
at any point most likely to rethink
how to make lifelong learners out of
people studying
this this class how to best equip them
for moving on
and continuing to develop in in the
field of philosophy
that i love so much um so that that's
part of what i'm doing i'm also doing a
lot of writing
this summer you'll see a lot of things
coming out in medium
maybe also in some other venues as well
but
we'll just hold off on that i'm also
doing a lot of writing hopefully for
book projects
that have been kind of stalled and i'm
working on a
co-written paper for a conference coming
up
in june specifically on aristotle
epictetus alexander of aphrodisias
simplicus dealing with uh you know
pro-racist
as a cause that's the faculty of choice
as as a cause so some metaphysics some
human nature some history of philosophy
some cool stuff there
video work you know i i have the
ambition at least
of of getting back to shooting six half
hour hegel
videos a month we'll see if that's
possible i'm also going to be doing some
book review
videos um one that i've been aiming to
get to for quite a long time you know
midlife a philosophical guide that that
i have to finally
uh get done with one that got sent to me
during the election that i wanted to
review um emergency kit for finding
common ground i think that could be
a useful thing to do another one that
was sent to me
by um you know princeton press in a
whole bunch of books
on mercy this looks very interesting and
then there's one that i checked out from
the library that's quite recent
barbara rosenweins anger the conflicted
history of an emotion so
i'm gonna shoot for reviewing all of
those um
by the way i i have um in amazon now
they let you upload videos
and i've uploaded a lot of my sadler's
honest reviews videos
into my amazon store which i'll put a
link to as well
so those are some videos i'm doing
one that i think people are going to be
kind of excited about
i don't know if i'm going to actually
get to review it in may
it may be in june but it's something
that people have been asking for for a
long time
and uh the the press finally sent me a
copy of the book
they bit the bullet because i kept on
saying hey
people are always asking hey can you do
stuff on nick land and i'd say send me a
copy of
fang fangnumina and i'll do it so one of
the editors wrote and said what's your
address
they sent it to me so i'm reading my way
through this right now i got to say that
the mystique that's developed around
this book and nick land in particular
seems a little mis
you know misplaced and mistaken because
it's pretty much
standard fare you know continental
philosophy
stuff it's not as mind-blowing as
as people have made it out to be but you
know i'm only a few
essays into it but i might get to review
it this month
might not we'll see what happens um
what else we'll do another caption
contest video
i've got to think of a good you know
picture to use with that
i'll probably do a few more personal
videos as well the sadler stories ones
and i am going to do something somebody
asked me you know
aleister mcintyre is somebody who's
important to your
work you've got like you know all this
stuff on like you know the john paul
sartre phase and nietzsche
phase and you know why you like plato
why isn't there a video on mcintyre
so i'm going to shoot a video on
mcintyre and my connections with
him and his work he's somebody who i
knew
personally i haven't interacted with him
for for quite a while so i can't say
that we're like you know
colleagues or anything but he is
somebody who's quite important so i'm
going to do something on that
i'm going to shoot some core concept
videos on
jill de luz's essay on bartleby the
scrivener
on foucause the subject in power
and then i'm also going to be doing
something kind of interesting as a
project
in in may so a long time ago
i shot using the same sort of half hour
hegel approach
i shot a whole bunch of videos roughly
half an hour each on epictetuses and
caridian and i put them into a different
channel
which was kind of a boneheaded thing to
do at the time so
what i'm going to do is take those
videos which don't have the best sound
quality
and remaster them i'm going to i'm going
to improve the sound quality as much
as i possibly can using some software
we'll see about if i can you know make
the lighting
a little bit more consistent than them
that may or may not be possible
and then i'm going to upload them in my
main channel
and switch out in the epictetus course
there's a free epictetus course by the
way on the encordian
that i've got i'm going to swap those
those videos out with each other
so that's what i'm going to do video
wise maybe maybe we'll do some other
things who knows
um you know you just have to watch the
channel
podcast uh you know i started releasing
those
uh podcast episodes on plato's ion and i
do have another plato thing coming up
this month i'm going to be releasing
some content on plato's perhaps greatest
dialogue the symposium
before that i'm going to be releasing
some a
short sequence of podcast episodes
on justin the emperor and his address to
the uneducated
uh cynics and then a sequence of
uh podcast episodes on michel foucault's
technologies of the self but then after
that it'll be plato's symposium so
a lot of stuff coming up in in may we'll
see if i can actually get to all of it
um sometimes you know it's you set the
bar high but you only make it halfway
but that's still better than doing
nothing so hopefully you can join me
at some of these online events and i'll
see you there
or you know in comments on the videos or
podcasts or
the writings or whatever it may happen
to be
you